non
habitué des micros bonjour donc je
m'appelle nicolas roussel je suis
chercheur en informatique chez narnia
lille donc moi je dire du monde
académique donc je suis assez basique on
m'a demandé si je pouvais parler de
liens ou de mouvement donc je vais vous
parler de mouvement et comme je suis
informaticien je vous parle et
d'informatique alors et puis comme ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas enseigner je
vais vous faire un cours et il y aura
des exercices à la fin pour la semaine
prochaine
donc moi domaines de recherche et
l'interaction machine et l'interaction
de machines c'est la science des
phénomènes qui se produisent quand une
ou plusieurs personnes utilisent un ou
plusieurs systèmes informatiques et donc
notre travail on cherche en interaction
machine c'est de comprendre ces
phénomènes et puis d'essayer de les
améliorer
et donc aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
mouvement et de deux types de mouvements
en fait don d'une part les mouvements
physiques et puis aussi le mouvement au
sens courant de pensée donc le mouvement
physique on peut le définir en disant
que c'est un déplacement dans l'espace
d'un corps ou deux parties d'un corps et
donc quand on fait de l'interaction
homme-machine du coup on va s'intéresser
soit au déplacement de la machine soit
au déplacement de l'homme a alors haussé
homme avec un h majuscule la parité
c'est parce que humain ça fait toujours
un peu bizarre et machines quand je dis
machine c'est n'importe quel système
informatique en fait donc moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les mouvements humains
et la manière dont ils sont pris en
compte dans les machines donc dans les
systèmes informatiques
alors on a une toute une batterie de
technologies qui existent aujourd'hui
pour capter et interpréter les
mouvements humains et ses technologies
se présente généralement sous la forme
d'objets qu'on tient dans sa main ou
qu'on porte sur soi ou pour touch ou
qu'on place dans notre environnement
immédiat
donc par exemple dans le domaine du jeu
vidéo
oui match pas si vous voyez ce que c'est
c'est la manette de la console wii de
nintendo c'est un truc qui ressemble un
peu à ça mais qui est blanc donc c'est
un exemple d'objets qu'on tient dans la
main et qui va détecter les mouvements
ont fait avec pour les transmettre à la
console de jeux les smartphones les
tablettes toutes ces choses là qu'on a
dans nos poches ou dans nos sacs c'est
aussi un exemple d'objets contient et
qu'on touche et qui est capable de
détecter les mouvements qu'on fait avec
et les mouvements qu'on fait sur surface
et puis des objets comme le kinect pour
rester dans le jeu vidéo qui est
périphérique de la console de jeu xbox
de microsoft
donc c'est un objet que vous placez dans
votre environnement typiquement sous
votre téléviseur et qui va être capable
de détecter les mouvements vous faites
face à lui alors derrière tous ces
objets en fait à peu près toujours le
même genre de technologie qu'on va
retrouver par exemple de la lumière
infrarouge projeter ou générés par des
diodes des caméras qui vont chercher
cette lumière infrarouge dans
l'environnement
il y en a une au bout de la wiimote par
exemple des accéléromètres des
gyroscopes pour mesurer les déplacements
linéaire et les rotations des objets
tenu par exemple et donc tout ça c'est
pour la partie électronique on va dire
et en plus de ça évidemment il ya du
logiciel avec des méthodes parfois très
sophistiqués qui sont implémentées dans
ses appareils de par exemple de vision
par ordinateur ou d'apprentissage
automatique
donc en fait de beaucoup d'intelligence
qui est mis dans ces objets donc on a
toute cette batterie de technologie qui
est à notre disposition pour mesurer
essayer d'interpréter les mouvements
humains mais finalement la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est pourquoi faire
pourquoi veux tu ont mesuré le mouvement
humain pourquoi est-ce qu'on pourquoi
est ce boulot finalement pourquoi on se
déplace on déplace des parties de notre
corps donc la première raison pour
laquelle on se déplacer pour se déplacer
justement c'est quand on rentre sur
scène où on en sort on se déplace
d'accord pour une fois ça m'a mis à part
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le mouvement
ont fait en gros trois grandes
catégories de choses on bouge pour mieux
percevoir ce qui est autour de nous on
bouge pour communiquer avec des choses
qui sont autour de goût et puis on bouge
pour agir sur des choses autour d'eux
et donc on va regarder ces trois
catégories la une par une
alors donc d'abord le mouvement comme
moyen de perception donc si je veux voir
plus précisément quelque chose de
typiquement je m'en approche ou si je
vois pas bien quelque chose qui est un
peu loin je me décalé pour changer de
point de vue si on me donne un objet que
je sais pas trop ce que c'est ni en quoi
il est fait je vais toucher l'objet puis
je vais éventuellement explorer sa
surface pour faire une idée de ce que
c'est tout ça c'est des mouvements qui
vise à apercevoir mieux les objets ou
l'environnement
et c'est des mouvements qui sont très
peu pris en compte dans les systèmes
informatiques aujourd'hui donc là je
vois certains trucs sur l'écran là je
peux m'approcher tant que je veux je
verrai pas tellement différemment que ce
que je vois de loin sur je le vois de
plus près mais je vois pas vraiment plus
de détails et les écrans tactiles de nos
tablettes et smartphones plein de choses
sont affichés dessus notamment des
boutons mais vous pouvez toucher tout ce
que vous voulez sur l'écran vous
sentirez jamais rien que du verre vous
sentez pas les objets qui sont décidés
dessus alors ça c'est vrai jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est en train de changer
donc il ya des gens dont moi qui ont
travaillé sur des systèmes qui change
qui a affiché en fonction de la distance
par exemple
et puis il ya des gens notamment
l'université de lille qui travaille sur
des solutions pour faire du retour
tactile sur les écrans tactiles pour que
peut-être demain on puisse sentir les
boutons qu'on voit mais qu'on ne sent
pas aux gens donc ça c'était pour le
mouvement moyen de perception alors donc
deuxième type de mouvements qu'on fait
régulièrement c'est le mouvement comme
moyen d'expression et le premier alors
oui mouvements humains souvent comme ça
passe par les mains on va parler de
geste est donc un geste très simple
qu'on fait exprimer quelque chose c'est
un geste de pointage ou un geste de
désignation donc on peut montrer
quelqu'un du doigt ça se fait pas le
faire avec quelqu'un que je connais ça
se fait mais là donc on peut montrer
quelqu'un du doigt l on peut désigner du
regard aussi ça marche aussi
on peut désigner par la parole en avant
la personne d'accord on met donc le
mouvement marche aussi pour désigner et
c'est un geste donc l'exploit s'il faut
communicatif
après derrière on peut
communiquer d'autres choses par moments
on peut dire toi tu sors par exemple ou
alors toi et moi on se téléphone et on
peut comme ça développe et plein de code
ou par par des gestes on va pouvoir
communiquer des choses donc ce qu'il ya
c'est que c'est un mode de communication
donc et donc il faut développer un
vocabulaire et de grammaire donc savoir
quand est-ce qu'on commence quand est-ce
qu'on finit et puis à qui on s'adresse
et donc quand on veut reconnaître ce
genre de mouvement par des systèmes
informatiques
on a ces deux problèmes là c'est de
savoir quand est-ce qu'on commence à
essayer de reconnaître quand est-ce
qu'on s'arrête à qui on s'adresse aussi
s'il ya qu un seul ordinateur dans la
pièce il peut penser que c'est toujours
lui comparses il y en a plusieurs sas a
accompli mais il se trouve que souvent
il ya quand même aussi des humains dans
la pièce et donc si je fais un mouvement
qui qui s'adresse à mes enfants mais qu'
il ya trois ordinateurs dans la pièce
qui croient que c'est à eux que je suis
en train de parler ça va être un peu
compliqué donc savoir quand est-ce qu'on
commence quand est-ce qu'on finit à qui
on s'adresse
et puis il faut développer de
vocabulaire qu'il faut trouver des
gestes qui vont être compréhensible par
les machines
et puis si possible que ces gestes
soient pas des gestes qu'on fait dans la
vie de tous les jours alors par exemple
vous allez dire retient aussi je fais un
truc comme ça
et bien c'est pour allumer la télé alors
le problème c'est que d'abord il faut
être assez souple et puis des gestes
comme ça on peut pas forcément en
inventer une cinquantaine et ou alors ça
va être difficile de s'en souvenir et ça
les gens sont pas forcément prêts à
faire ce travail d'apprentissage donc la
troisième catégorie de mouvement c'est
le mouvement pour agir sur
l'environnement donc de souvent ce qu'on
fait une fois qu'on a désigné quelque
chose donc soit c'est une entité qui
comprend ce qu'on peut lui dire et donc
on peut lui dire fais quelque chose ou
alors c'est un objet ou de la matière
inerte et dans ce cas là on va agir
dessus
donc je peux aller attraper un objet le
déplacer l'ouvrir le fermer le tir et le
manipuler donc manipuler ces cantons à
ses doigts sur l'objet et louanges
interagit avec ce qui est sur l'écran de
mon smartphone je manipule les choses
puisque j'ai les doigts dessus quand je
fais des gestes devant un kinect et que
je touche rien en fait je suis plutôt un
mode de communication pas dans un mode
d'action directe
alors là je vais vous parler d'un
périphérique extraordinaire que vous
connaissez tous mais dont vous
soupçonnez pas à quel point il est
extraordinaire en fait donc selah sue
rim alors la souris ça a été inventé
dans les années 1960 c'était popularisé
dans les années 1980-1990 vous
l'utilisez depuis très longtemps mais
vous êtes vous déjà demandé en fait
comment ça fonctionne une souris ce cas
derrière et pourquoi ça marche pourquoi
on arrive à faire tant de choses sur un
ordinateur de type bureau ou un
ordinateur portable avec une souris
alors en fait la souris c'est un
dispositif parfaitement conçu pour faire
du pointage alors la souris je vous
montre là c'est une souris un peu
spécial c'est une souris pour gamer donc
pour les gens qui passent beaucoup de
temps à jouer et donc qui utilisent la
souris pendant de longues heures
donc elle a une forme qui est
particulièrement ergonomique
ça se voit pas forcément le dessus elle
a un capteur qui est à très haute
résolution dont qui peut mesurer des
déplacements de l'ordre du centième ou
du millième de millimètre et avec mille
fois par seconde donc des déplacements
très fin et très souvent hélas alors on
le voit un petit peu sur le côté il ya
des petites masque on peut insérer dans
le corps de la souris pour ajuster son
poids parce que quand c'est quelque
chose qu'on utilise le pendant très
longtemps on a envie qu'elle est qu'elle
soit plus ou moins légère après il ya
des tapis spéciaux qu'on va mettre
dessus de souvent que ça que les six
mois et alors tout ça c'est la partie
matérielle la partie visible de la
sonnerie et après il ya une autre partie
que vous voyez pas qu'est ce qui se
passe dans l'ordinateur quand vous
pouvez la souris donc quand vous bougez
votre souris de 20 cm vers la droite
ses passions vous soyez déjà demandé de
combien ça bouge à l'écran est en fait
la réponse et sa dépendance à dépenser
vous bouger vite ou pas vite
donc si vous bougez lentement ça va
bouger peu sur l'écran si vous j'ai vite
ça va bouger très loin sur l'écran et la
raison c'est assez pour que vous
puissiez faire des mouvements à la fois
précis et puis en même temps des
mouvements très ample à l'écran mais
sans forcément devoir faire des
mouvements très ample physiquement sinon
vous serez obligés d'avoir des bureaux
de deux mètres de large
vu la taille des écrans d'aujourd'hui
d'accord en fait ce truc là qui fait le
lien entre le mouvement physique que
vous faites sur votre table et puis le
mouvement qui se passe à l'écran ça
s'appelle une fonction de transfert et
avec jerry casier qui est un collègue de
l'université de lille on s'est intéressé
à ça depuis quelques années on a
découvert des trucs fantastiques sur des
différences entre les systèmes suivants
les ordinateurs qu'on utilise les
limites de ses fonctions et des quelques
idées sur comment on pourrait encore
recevoir de nouvelles donc à tout un
tout une science en fait là dedans qui
est en train de se développer sur
comment faire pour concevoir les ses
fonctions transfert de la manière la
plus adaptée à certaines tâches alors la
souris c'est aussi un dispositif
parfaitement conçu pour la manipulation
est déjà le premier point intéressant
c'est que les sont dissociés la souris
vous pouvez pointer un objet à l'écran
sans agir dessus chose qui est difficile
à faire sur un écran comme ça où dès que
vous mettez votre toit sur un bouton en
général ça déclenche l'action qui est
derrière le bouton est alors à quoi ça
sert de pouvoir désigner un objet sans
agir dessus basse à faire par exemple à
savoir ce que ça fait donc les tout le
type ou les infobulles en français qui
s'affiche sur les boutons sur votre
écran quand vous amenez la souris dessus
et qui vous disent que vous allez
pouvoir faire si vous cliquez sur
l'objet c'est parce qu'on a dissocié le
comptage de l'action notre l'open un
autre bon point pour la souris c'est que
elle a plusieurs boutons donc ça c'est
un cas extrême elle en a combien 5-6-7
plus la molette qui est spécial pour le
défilement et ça ça veut dire qu'avec le
même genre d'action physique mais en
changeant le bouton vous allez pouvoir
déclencher différentes actions dans le
monde informatique et ça ça résout le
problème que je tenais tout à l'heure de
comment je construis mon vocabulaire
comment je choisis mes mes gestes mal à
le vider ses je change de gestes en
changeant de boutons fini et puis
évidemment on peut faire des double clic
des tripes le clic des 2000 clic et ça
renforce encore le nombre augmente
encore le nombre de possibilités
alors pourquoi je vous parle de la
souris en fait
parce que ça renvoie pour moi un à cette
phrase de rex et semaines donc il dit en
gros que quelque chose de bien conçu ça
saute pas forcément aux yeux du premier
coup les choses qui sont bien conçues
comme quand on les utilise tout se passe
bien et tout se passe comme on aimerait
que ça se passe bien on a tendance à
penser que c'est normal et on comprend
pas spécialement pourquoi cette chose et
les fantastiques et la souris c'est un
peu ça c'est vous l'utilisez tous depuis
sans doute très longtemps et vous avais
jamais pensé comment ça marche
et en fait moi je vous le dis ça marche
super bien ça marche extrêmement bien et
ça marche beaucoup mieux que tout un tas
d'autres dispositifs dont ceux que j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure la wiimote le
kinect tout un tas d'autres trucs pour
un an un grand ensemble de tâches donc
évidemment il ya des choses qu'on peut
faire plus de manière plus confortable
sur ce genre de dispositif que assis sur
un bureau avec un clavier une souris
mais c'est par là c'est juste pas les
mêmes choses
donc ce qui m'amène à la partie la
présentation sur le mouvement au sens
courant de pensée et donc le jeu là je
vous parlais de plusieurs idées reçues
on va dire sur le développement de
l'informatique et en particulier de tout
ce qui touche à l'interface homme
machine et à l'interaction homme-machine
donc la première idée on entend souvent
c'est que à chaque fois qu'un nouveau
dispositif sort forcément il va
remplacer tous ceux d'avant et donc moi
je crois que c'est fondamentalement
fausse cette histoire là donc la souris
et clavier ou encore de grandeur
devereux parce que complètement on n'a
pas fait mieux qu'un clavier physique
pour taper du texte
moi je prends prédit qu'on ne fera pas
beaucoup mieux voire jamais mieux qu'une
souris pour pointer efficacement à la
fois très vite très loin et en même
temps très finement et donc toutes ces
nouvelles interfaces qui apparaissent et
qui tire parti d'un mouvement libre dont
on dit qu'ils sont plus simples et
naturels plus intuitif passé des choses
qui viennent compléter la souris le
clavier est ce qu'on avait déjà c'est
pas des choses qui vont forcément les
remplacer même chose qui les
remplaceront pas là j'ai parlé de la
simple naturelle et intuitive ça m'amène
à ma deuxième question ça c'est les
travaux pratiques pour la semaine
prochaine
il faut réfléchir sur tout ça donc
l'informatique doit-elle être simple
intuitive et naturel
donc ça fait des années qu'on nous dit
que c'est vers ça qu'il faut aller c'est
un argument de vente fantastique et bien
moi je pense que c'est une grosse erreur
en fait y'a pas de raison encore faire
ses lacets c'est compliqué lire c'est
compliqué écrire c'est compliqué comté
s'est compliquée jouer au tennis jouer
de la guitare faire de ce qui conduirait
de voiture c'est super compliqué et on a
tous de passer un temps impressionnant à
apprendre à conduire à jouer de la
musique à faire du sport faire ses
lacets c'est juste qu'on s'en souvient
pas parce qu'une fois qu'on l'a appris
avec suffisamment de pratique on remet
ça naturellement
alors pour le coup j'utilise ce mot que
j'aime pas naturel et donc les matins
quand vous emmenez vos enfants à l'école
vous écouter la radio vous leur parlez
tout en regardant un tout petit peu dans
le rétroviseur si le paiement de deux
tonnes qui arrive à 80 derrière vous va
pas vous percutez d'accord et vous
n'avez pas l'impression prendre un
risque phénoménal parce que vous avez
intégré tout un tas de choses dans la
conduite de la voiture
et contrairement à ce que beaucoup de
gens pensent la voiture et pas
spécialement intelligente aujourd'hui il
ya plein de trucs intelligents dans la
voiture mais dans la conduite de la
voiture il ya pas tant d'intelligence
que ça mais pourquoi on est prêt à
passer un temps colossal à apprendre
tout un tas de choses qu'on va utiliser
un peu de temps en temps et que on n'est
pas prêt à passer notre presque trois
minutes à apprendre le fonctionnement
d'un dispositif comme celui là où comme
un ordinateur portable ou n'importe quel
autre système informatique qu'on risque
d'utiliser beaucoup plus souvent que sa
mobylette sa voiture ou sa guitare ça
c'est quelque chose que je comprends pas
j'ai parlé aussi déjà plusieurs fois
d'intelligence donc ça c'est une autre
question intéressante c'est où est-ce
qu'on veut l'intelligence en fait donc
ont fabriqué des systèmes très
intelligent très sophistiqué qui
implémente des algorithmes très
compliqué pour détecter ce qu'on veut
faire essayer de deviner ce qu'on veut
faire et le faire à notre place
c'est une façon de faire de
l'informatique
on peut aussi se demander si on veut pas
fabriquer des outils informatiques qui
au lieu d'être intelligents permettent
aux gens d'exprimer au mieux leur
intelligence voire soyons fous même de
la développer et donc moi je préférerais
qu'on aille vers ça
et donc pour conclure je vous montre une
photo de ma tasse à café que j'utilise
tous les jours sur 7 ha ça qui a fait
vous voyez thor le dieu de la mythologie
nordique et dans sa main gauche il tient
mieux le dire son marteau écrire mieux
venir c'est un exercice difficile en soi
et c'est un bon exercice justement pour
envoyer à cette idée que tout doit pas
forcément être simple donc mieux venir
c'est un marteau fantastique déclenché
la foudre on peut voler avec quand on
lance il revient dans la main de celui
qui l'a lancé
donc il donne le pouvoir de dieu du
tonnerre à celui qui lui tient mais il
ya juste un truc c'est que en fait tout
le monde peut pas le soulever il faut en
être digne ça se mérite
et pourtant c'est qu'un marteau c'est
pas un truc intelligent qui agit à la
place de celui qui le possède
c'est juste un outil mais c'est un outil
qui se mérite et je pense que ça
illustre assez bien ce faire je crois je
pense qu'il faudrait aller c'est-à-dire
des outils informatiques qui exploite au
mieux nos capacités de perception de
contrôle d'apprentissage qui font pas
forcément grand chose voire qu'ils font
rien en eux mêmes mais et pour
lesquelles on est prêt à investir quand
même un peu de notre temps pour les
mériter
voilà tout vous remercie de votre
attention